miren nosotros lo que hemos documentado
es como la corrupción tiene un impacto
enorme en la en la protección de los
derechos de Derechos Humanos en Honduras
que es uno de los países más pobres de
América Latina hemos visto la
malversación de fondos que estaban
destinados precisamente para el combate
contra la pobreza para la capacitación
de Pequeños agricultores para el combate
contra el dengue para la salud desvío de
fondos por ejemplo durante la pandemia
de covid y lo que es necesario es una
una acción decisiva para que eso no
ocurra porque porque en cuanto se esté
continúen este tipo de de actos de
corrupción va a ser muy difícil una una
protección adecuada de los Derechos
Humanos en Honduras claro la presidenta
Xiomara Castro asumió con un enfoque
bastante enfocado en la lucha contra la
corrupción de hecho acordó una visita de
la ONU para aceptar las bases de la
comisión contra la corrupción hubo
avances en este sentido durante esta
primera parte de su mandato
Mire es muy positivo que la presidenta
Xiomara Castro
se presentó a las elecciones con una
plataforma anticorrupción y lo refrendó
cuando asumió la presidencia pero
estamos a un año y medio de ella estar
en el poder y realmente creemos que
necesita necesitamos agilizar esas
acciones con medidas concretas y entre
esas medidas yo destacaría primero la
creación de una comisión
internacional
acordada con la ONU para para combatir
la corrupción en Honduras
eliminar leyes que han sido aprobadas en
los últimos años precisamente para
dificultar el combate contra la
corrupción han sido elaboradas por
personas que estaban implicadas en en
hechos ilícitos y el tercer elemento que
es fundamental es tener un sistema
judicial que funcione un sistema
judicial que sea verdaderamente
independiente y en ese sentido es
crucial la elección de un fiscal general
en base al mérito es una elección que va
a ocurrir este año y donde queremos ver
que la mejor persona ocupa el cargo por
sus méritos y sus capacidades y no por
vinculación con partidos políticos Claro
cuéntenos En qué estado se encuentra el
proceso y las negociaciones para crear
esta comisión respaldada por la ONU
contra la corrupción e impunidad en
Honduras
Sí hay un memorando de entendimiento que
fue firmado en diciembre del año pasado
y ahora está prevista una una visita de
unos expertos de la ONU para
establecer como las bases de esa de esa
comisión nosotros creemos que es muy
importante que que se cree ha pasado
bastante tiempo y es urgente que que se
instale y que la comisión realmente el
valor que tiene es fortalecer las
capacidades locales en términos de
capacitación de Fiscales hondureños
trabajo conjunto y que promueva una
reforma digamos más amplia del sistema
judicial
para tratar casos de corrupción y otros
tipos de casos lo que vemos ahora es una
impunidad enorme y es la impunidad es el
digamos el la Simiente o el origen de
nuevos casos de corrupción en cuanto
mientras no se castigue el robo del
dinero público eso va a continuar